- [Kelly] (indistinct)
- Thank you,
Enjoyed the dancing grandmother.
- Did you? I know, she
left something for me,
so I'm just gonna keep it.
I'm just kidding, we'll get it to you.
Do you dance? Do you dance like that?
Your hips move like that?
- Yes. Modern interpretive
dance is my life. Yes. Yes.
(Kelly laughs)
(audience laughs)
Yes. I think that all men, oh really,
what's more fun than that?
But my favorite part is
the grandmother's only
eight years older than I
am. It just makes me laugh.
- [Kelly] (laughs) I'm just
saying, you need to keep up.
You gotta keep up with
her. She's a firecracker.
- I know, I know.
- Oh my gosh.
So wait, you've spent much
of your life hosting TV
so do you also enjoy watching TV?
- Yeah, I like TV, I.
- [Kelly] Okay.
Well I don't know. (laughs)
- Let me ask you something.
Let me ask the guys, okay. Some guys.
My wife loves animals.
- Oh, me too.
- Any kind of show with
anima- baby Llamas, you know,
kittens, puppy, Discovery Channel?
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- You know,
YouTube cat vi- okay, fine.
So one night I'm watching one
of my, I love Law and Order.
I'm watching Law and Order, okay.
We got about 10 minutes into
the show and my wife goes
"We gotta turn it off."
Why what's, "'Cause I think
the boyfriend's gonna come back
and hurt the girl's cat."
I go, "Honey, first of
all, it's an acting cat.
He's not really getting hurt."
(audience laughs)
(Kelly laughs)
"Right, I mean, your
putting a cat outta work."
"No, I don't wanna."
"But it's not a real."
"No, I don't care.
I don't wanna see an animal get h-."
Oh, okay. You know, I
respect this. I fine.
Two weeks ago I'm watching some
Danish thriller on Netflix.
Okay. Husband's on the ground.
Wife stabbing him 68 times.
61. 62. 63, 64.
My wife's like this.
(audience laughs)
(Kelly laughs)
I'm going "Are you okay with this?"
She goes "Yeah's a good
show, don't you think?"
I, what am I missing?
What am I missing here?
(audience claps)
Exactly. Exactly.
(grunts)
- She values (laughs)
She values animals more.
- She's watching like
this. Really? Really?
You think that's it?
Well, I'm stunned.
Well, thanks for clearing that up.
- Oh my God, that's amazing.
Speaking of TV are you a guy
that always gets the latest
tech? Are you that person?
You have to like, update
it every time some-
- Let me tell you about
the latest tech, okay?
(Kelly laughs)
I go to Best Buy right down here.
- Love Best Buy.
- Okay. And I'm looking
for a washer dryer.
So the guy says to me,
"Let me show you a new line
of smart washers and dryers."
I say, "What makes 'em smart?"
The guy says, "Well they
got WiFi, you know."
I said "You know, I don't need
WiFi in my washer and dryer."
The guy says, "No, no, it's added value.
You buy the top of the line model
you get the WiFi for free."
I say okay.
So I buy the wash and dryer and the WiFi.
For the last two weeks,
I'm walking around with damp underwear
'cause I forgot my password. Okay, okay.
(Kelly laughs)
(audience laughs)
I'm just saying, I'm just saying.
- I never get it either.
All the like, yeah. I
never do all the things
they tell you you can do with them.
- Yeah, why do you need
Wi- It's so stupid.
- I don't need it to be smart.
I just need it, yeah.
- This is a password thing.
That drives me crazy.
You know, I, for some
reason my Netflix went
off and then, oh, I want to get it back.
So now I gotta go through Mother's maiden.
I'm on the phone for an hour.
Mother's maiden name, and so and so,
it's like, I, you know, the
password's just simple, now,
"Well, we've gotta check." (indistinct)
It took an hour. Okay.
Then my bank calls, okay.
(audience laughs)
My bank calls like two weeks later.
"You're transferring this amount
of money to this account."
Oh yeah. Yeah.
And what's your name? I'm
saying "I'm Jay Leno."
"Okay. Thank you."
I go, wha- That's it? That's it?
(Kelly laughs)
I, I mean, I don't care if you steal my
Netflix movie, but my banking, really?
(audience laughs)
(Kelly laughs)
I mean it really, it
was, "Is this Jay Leno?"
"Yes it is." "Okay, great."
But wait, how do you know it's me?
- [Kelly] Oh my God.
- How do you know it's me?
It's like, well, it's crazy.
- That's so true.
Ted kills me every time.
I don't even try anymore.
I just have friends that I
call that say, "Help me."
- But why do we need to
know all this, really?
- Yeah. And it's like if you knew
how incredibly easy my
passwords are. (laughs)
- Yeah. Everybody's password.
- I'm just like, there's too many.
- Exactly, exactly.
(audience applauds)
- We're back with Jay Leno,
and that was him hosting You Bet Your Life
So the show looks very fun.
Glad she got to touch your hair.
Do you have any favorite
moments from this season?
- Well, it really a comedy game show.
A comedy show with a game element.
You know, my favorite thing we used to do
in the Tonight Show is Jaywalk.
And we would just
knock on doors.
- [Kelly] Yeah, I love, yeah.
- And ask people questions,
and it's basically that.
And then we just kind
of throw money at 'em.
But it's amazing how people just don't,
'cause I give 'em clues
to give them money, okay.
A guy comes out with a, I mean
a guy had a sweatshirt on,
it said fire something on it.
I don't know what it
was, a band or something.
And I said, "Okay, where
there's smoke, there's,"
"Trees." No.
(Kelly gasps)
Okay, "Smoke, there's,"
"A chimney." No "Smoke, there's,"
"House." No.
I'm thinking it's on your shirt.
It says fire on your shirt.
- Does it take all of you?
- How can you, you know, I said,
"I'm trying to give you
money. I want you to win.
The audience wants you to win."
No, couldn't get it
(kelly laughs)
(audience laughs)
- Okay, wait
you recently had President
Biden on Jay Leno's Garage.
- [Jay Leno] Right, right, right.
- So let's see a bit of that.
- So as electric cars a big part
of your climate bill,
- A gigantic part.
- Yeah.
- And also part of the,
what people don't realize,
it was part of the infrastructure bill,
you know building the
highways and the like.
'Cause we're talking about
putting 500,000 charging stations
and the money for those charging
stations is in that bill,
in addition to the charging
stations individual companies
are putting in.
So it's, you know, it's a game changer.
You got 40% of all pollution,
all the CO2 going up is from a tail pipe.
- [Jay Leno] Right.
- And imagine if we just changed that.
- Well actually-
- I mean, wait, what was
it like to ride around
with the president of the United States?
That's.
- Well, you know, it's interesting.
When you become President of the States,
you lose your license for life.
You're never allowed to drive a car again.
Do you know that?
- What?
- You do. Yeah. Because you
have to be driven everywhere.
That's the law.
You can. Obama, Bush.
You can drive on private property.
So what we did was
President Biden in 1967,
when he got married,
his dad gave him a new Corvette as a gift.
And he still has it, but
the only place he gets to
drive it is when we go to some,
we went to the Secret
Service Training Center where
they teach high speed driving, you know,
the Evasive maneuvers,
and he was having a ball.
He's just flying around,
and the secrets are
"Slow him down, slow him down."
them, they're just yelling
and he's burning rubber.
And it was a lot of fun.
We had a great time,
because he's not, you're
not allowed to drive.
- So that's the only time
- [Kelly] I didn't know that
- he gets to drive a car. So
that's why he was anxious.
- That's such a weird rule.
- And it's really funny when the President
of the United States calls you.
'Cause having, with
President Obama and Bush,
this is what you, it
normally goes like this.
"Hello, This is the White
House calling, are you able to
accept the call from the
President of United States?"
I said, "Yes."
"Is this Jay Leno?"
"Yes." "Can you hang on one moment, sir."
Then you wait "Jay." President
Obama, President Bush.
I'm home one day, Ring "Jay. It's Joe,
(audience laughs)
Joe Biden."
I go, Oh, Joe Biden, President
of the United States.
(audience laughs)
He goes, "Yeah." And then we talked about
what we gonna do on the,
it just made me laugh.
It just made me laugh.
- Cause usually it's,
it's more like,
- Yeah it's a whole
It's all a whole.
- It's like an ordeal usually,
yeah.
- Oh, it's a whole big deal,
- I love that.
You know what's so interesting?
He, they are like that.
They're both like that Jill and Joe,
because they called my mother.
(audience laughs)
- [Jay Leno] Yeah.
- Because she was a teacher.
They literally called my mother.
- [Jay Leno] Well they-
- My mother was on the phone
with the President and the
First Lady and just like,
(indistinct).
Like, you know. Yeah, they're so nice.
- Well, when they're not President,
they're just regular people.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- You know, President Obama once,
when I had him on the, you know,
I called him the week he announced,
before anybody knew who he was,
I invited him on the
Tonight Show, you know,
and, 'cause everybody thought Hillary had
it in the bag, you know.
So he came in and he go,
"Jay, my name's Barack Hussein Obama
I'm running for president
of the United States."
I said, "Okay, well let's
look at the odds here.
Black guy named Hussein from Chicago,
(audience laughs)
(Kelly laughs)
nobody ever heard of him.
"Nah, you're gonna win pal.
You gotta be a shoo-in." you know.
(audience laughs and claps)
(Kelly laughs)
And you know, he was very funny,
he had a great sense of humor.
So he and I became friends and he gave
me his cell phone number.
So I said, so I tell one
day, I'm telling my friend.
Now you know how this is, when
you come from a small town,
you have the same idiot
friends your whole life
that you grew up with, you know.
So I'm telling my friends, you know,
"I got Obama's cell phone."
"Let's call 'im up."
You know, I go, "We're
not gonna call him."
He go, "You don't have it."
"Nuh-uh". "Uh-huh." "Nuh-uh." Uh-huh."
And, what, like 45 year
old men, were going,
"Nuh-uh." "Uh-huh." "Nuh-uh."
Okay. So finally my friend
said, No, you don't have it.
I said, "First of all
it's probably shut off
since he's president".
Well if he shut off, let's call it.
I said, "What time? It's
three o'clock in California.
Okay, it's 12 (indistinct). All right."
I dial the number. I hear, "Barack here."
"Oh, Mr. President.
Yeah, it's Jay Leno." "What
can I do for you Jay?"
"Should I throw this number away?"
"Good idea, Jay." Click.
And that was, you know.
(audience laughs)
- I was like, you didn't have a plan.
- No, I didn't think he
was gonna answer the phone.
- Oh my God, you have, I
"Oh, I was just calling about
the crisis in, and if you
needed any help, like."
(indistinct)
- Yeah, you know, exactly.
- Oh my God.
None of my friends care what I do.
They don't care whose number I have.
I'm not cool.
- [Jay Leno] What?
- Your friends still think you're cool.
- Well no, they don't
really think I'm cool.
But, you, when you know what it is when
- [Kelly] It's pretty cool to have Barack-
- You have the same idiot
friends that you what you
- [Kelly] 100%.
- Yeah, yeah.
- I mean, I'm not calling them idiots.
So shut up. April, Mary. (laughs)
- I'm calling mine idiots.
- [Kelly] That's a guy thing.
- I'm calling them idiots.
- Girls aren't like, "That's cool."
Okay, we need another break.
But you can see Jay
host Jay Leno's Garage,
Wednesdays on CNBC.
And check your local listings
for where to watch You Bet Your Life.